The tricky thing about this problem is that I don't know if I need to break it into two parts or not.
Will the bicyclist catch up with the runner in the first 4 s?
Or will it take more than that? I just don't know.
But what I can do is figure out how far the bicyclist and how far the runner will go in those first 4 s.
And if the bicyclist's distance is greater than or equal to the runner's, I know he's caught up.
And then I can just worry about this being a one part problem.
So let's see. How far will the bicyclist go in 4 s?
This is the same calculation we did in the first problem, and it's 24 m.
And I can use the same equation to describe the runner's motion with an acceleration of 0
and an initial velocity of 6, the runner goes 24 m.
She's gone just as far as the bicyclist has, so it turns out by luck
that after 4 s the bicyclist catches up with the runner.
Note that both the runner and the cyclist have gone 24 m in the first 4 s.
It's interesting to notice that this 24 m is actually equal to the area underneath this triangle
and also the area underneath this rectangle.
This isn't a coincidence but rather an important physical fact.
If you've ever taken a calculus class or plan to take one in the future,
you can learn more about why this exciting phenomenon happens.